muy bien vamos a hacer algunos
ejercicios de cómo vamos a medir
longitudes y el primero nos dice qué
opción muestra la longitud del borrador
medida correctamente muy bien entonces
tenemos un borrador digamos rosa y
tenemos varias formas de medir la verdad
así que la primera de ellas nos dice que
dos reglas estas son dos reglas de un
centímetro digamos dos reglas miden al
borrador y dejan un espacio y en efecto
aquí vemos un espacio pero esta es una
forma muy mala de medirlo verdad porque
además nos está sobrando digamos está
esta medida de la regla del lado derecho
así que definitivamente esta es una
forma muy mala de medir el borrador
vamos a ver qué pasaría con esta segunda
opción dice dos reglas miden al borrador
y se traslapan verdad y aquí podemos ver
que es ligeramente más oscuro justamente
para para indicar que se están
trasladando a ambas reglas pero podemos
ver que tampoco es una buena forma
a este borrador porque nos falta nos
falta medir alguna cantidad del lado
derecho verdad aquí terminan digamos las
dos reglas y aún así nos sobra un pedazo
así que esta también es una muy mala
forma de medir al borrador vamos a ver
qué pasa con esta tercera dice y dice
dos reglas miren al borrador de un
extremo a otro verdad y esta es una
forma adecuada de medir la verdad
tenemos estas dos reglas que sólo se
tocan digamos en digamos en sus extremos
en su en su extremo y miden
perfectamente bien la longitud de este
borrador así que esta sería la respuesta
correcta
muy bien hagamos otro ejercicio dice que
opción muestra la longitud del
rectángulo medida correctamente y esto
es algo muy similar al ejercicio que
teníamos anteriormente verdad dice la
primera opción dice tres reglas miden el
rectángulo y dejan un espacio verdad
entonces podemos ver que este es una
mala forma de medir la verdad es muy
similar a lo que hicimos en el caso
anterior nuevamente estas tres reglas si
está si dejamos este espacio también se
exceden del lado derecho así que no es
una buena forma de medir este rectángulo
que pasaría por ejemplo una segunda
opción dice tres reglas miden al
rectángulo y se traslapan y nuevamente
no es una forma adecuada de medirlo
porque aunque aquí vemos que se
traslapan estas dos reglas vemos que
falta un pedazo del rectángulo por medir
así que esta no es una buena opción qué
pasaría con la tercera dice tres reglas
miden al rectángulo de un lado
al otro y eso tiene todo el sentido del
mundo porque estas reglas se tocan solo
en su borde y miden muy bien la longitud
de este rectángulo así que la respuesta
correcta sería la tercera veamos en
efecto fue una buena respuesta
veamos este otro ejercicio dice que
opción muestra cómo medir correctamente
la longitud del rectángulo y aquí dice
el rectángulo mide 8 metros pero está
muy mal verdad porque está midiendo un
metro que en realidad no pertenece al
rectángulo así que esta primera opción
no es correcta la segunda dice el
rectángulo mide 7 metros
y esta es una muy buena respuesta porque
empieza a medir en digamos empieza a
medir en este extremo del rectángulo y
nos va contando cuántos metros mide
verdad y nos dice que es de 7 metros así
que esta sería nuestra opción digamos
como como buena respuesta ahora vamos a
ver que la tercera opción no es una
buena respuesta muy bien y lo que
podemos observar es que aunque dice que
el rectángulo mide 9 metros y parecería
que si en realidad hay 2 metros que está
contando y que no pertenecen a la
longitud del rectángulo así que esta
tercera opción no es correcta y nos
quedamos con la segunda muy bien hagamos
ahora este ejercicio dice cuál es el
ancho de la caja de manzanas en metros y
nos dicen arrastra la regla para hacer
la medición escribe un número natural
muy bien entonces podemos nosotros mover
esta regla para tratar de ver cuánto
mide digamos la el ancho de la caja de
manzanas verdad en metros muy bien así
que podemos fácilmente fácilmente
acomodar la regla aquí muy bien
y ya que hemos acomodado la regla
justamente debajo de nuestra caja de la
manzana podemos ver que tiene una
longitud o un ancho digamos de un metro
también tenemos un metro y podemos
verificar esta respuesta está correcta y
vamos a hacer un último ejercicio dice
qué opción muestra cómo medir
correctamente la longitud del rectángulo
y nuevamente aquí esta no es una buena
opción porque nos está contando un metro
que no tiene el rectángulo y nuestra
segunda opción es quizás la más adecuada
verdad porque nos está midiendo desde un
extremo al otro que mide nos está
diciendo que mide cuatro metros verdad
así que es nuestra mejor opción mientras
que la tercera opción dice el rectángulo
mide 10 metros pero eso no es cierto
porque nos está contando 6 metros que no
están en el rectángulo así que vamos a
concluir que el rectángulo mide 4 metros
y eso es correcto